hey this is press to
Walker in this video I will present
three different problems about
calculating shaded areas that involve
circles problem one we have the
following diagram and we need to figure
out the area of the Shaded region which
looks like a
claw if each of the three semicircles
below has an area equal to 72 and Q is
the midpoint of p r what is the area of
the Shaded
region I saw this problem posted online
and the person said it was a PSAT
question this is one of the standardized
test that students in America take and
for context it's usually given when
students are about 15 or 16 years old so
this is before most of them would learn
any sort of
trigonometry problem two a regular
hexagon has a side length equal to two
in the interior of the hexagon construct
a semicircle on on each side the
question is what is the Shaded area
equal to that is what is the area that's
interior to the hexagon that's not
covered by any of the
semicircles this problem comes from a
mathematical Olympiad qualifying test in
America the 2020
amc10b problem
14 problem three start with the square
and construct the midpoint of each side
of the square
at Each corner of the square construct a
semicircle centered at the corner at
each midpoint of each side construct a
semicircle centered at the midpoint of
each
side then in each quarter Circle Mark
the region that's not overlapping with
the semicircle in
Orange this will be four areas for the
semicircle Mark the areas that are not
overlapping with each quarter Circle in
blue this will be a total of four areas
if the side of the square has a length
equal to S the quarter Circle has a
radius equal to three and each
semicircle has a radius equal to
two what is the difference in areas
between the orange areas and the blue
areas I want to thank Andre for the
suggestion and this comes from a junior
mathematical
Olympiad pause the video if you'd like
to give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
[Music]
problems let's solve problem one the
area of this claw will be equal to the
area of the common region between the
flat semicircle and the Tilted
semicircle minus the area that's common
between the two flat
semicircles and then we need to add back
in this area which we subtracted out so
this is a 20°
sector so we have a simple equation now
since all three semicircles have the
same area of 72 all three semicircles
are
congruent so the common region between
any two of these semicircles will
exactly be equal to each other so these
two areas will cancel out so the area of
this claw is exactly equal to the area
of a circular sector that has a central
angle of 20° now we were given that each
semicircle has an area equal to 72 and
each semicircle spans
180° so this area is equal to the area
of a semicircle multiplied by 20 over
180 and that equals 72 multiplied 1 over
9 which is equal to 8 and that's the
answer now let's solve problem two there
are many approaches to solve this
question but I will show one that I find
visually
interesting First Connect opposite
vertices of the hexagon to divide the
hexagon into six equilateral
triangles then connect midpoints of
sides that are two sides apart this will
create a mesh of equilateral triangles
so now the area that we want to
calculate is exactly equal to 6 * the
area of one of these blue
slices but what's the area of one blue
slice notice that each side length is
equal to two and each semicircle spans
the side length as its diameter so the
radius of each semicircle is equal to
one that means each equilateral triangle
has a side length equal to 1 and the
radius of the circular sector is equal
to 1 furthermore since we have
equilateral triangles the central angle
will be equal to
60° so let's now calculate the area of
one of these blue slices it's equal to
the area of two equilateral triangles
minus the area of a circular
sector so each equilateral triangle has
an area that's equal to s^2 < tk3 4 so
we want 2 * that then we want want PK r^
2 * 60 /
360 now each equilateral triangle has a
side length equal to 1 and this circular
sector has a radius that's equal to 1 so
s^2 = R2 = 1 so we substitute this in to
get 2 < tk3 4- < /
6 let's now simplify this to a fraction
with the denominator of 6 and this is
equal to 3 < tk3 - piun all over 6
now the area we want is exactly six
times this area and this simplifies to
be 3 < tk3 minus Pi which is
approximately
2.05 and that's the
answer now let's solve problem three I
have to admit when I first saw this
problem I was stumped my first approach
was to try to figure out the area that's
intersecting between the quarter Circle
and the semicircle but this turns out to
be a very complicated and difficult
calculation so after many months of
putting the problem aside I thought
there has to be an easier way so here's
how I thought about it and I just struck
magic so I thought Let each of the
orange areas have an area that's equal
to a
units let the overlap between the
quarter Circle and the semicircle have
an area equal to B units and let each of
these blue regions have an area of C
units Now by symmetry this will also be
B units on the other side of the quarter
Circle same thing in the
semicircle so now our problem can be
translated in terms of a b and c four
orang areas will be equal to 4 a and we
want to subtract 4 C so all we need to
do is figure out 4 A minus 4
C furthermore A+ 2 B will be equal to
the area of one qu Circle then the area
of the semicircle will be C +
2B and now comes the magic we'll
multiply each of these equations by four
so we have 4 a + 8 B is equal to 4 * the
area of a quarter Circle then we have 4
C + 8 B is equal to 4 * the area of a
semicircle all we have to do now is
subtract the second equation from the
first and the B terms will cancel out so
we have 4 Aus 4 C is equal to 4 * the
area of a quarter Circle minus 4 * the
area of a
semicircle each of these areas can be
easily
calculated we know the radius of each
quarter circle is 3 so the area of each
quarter circle is < * 3^ 2 all over 4 we
know the radius of each semicircle is 2
so the area of each semicircle is pi *
2^ 2 / 2 just going through the
arithmetic we get that 4 a - 4 C is
equal to Pi and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time